Hello everybody!
Hello hu- do you like my tiny hat?
I figured, so, welcome to Goodnight Dragoons Fishing Edition.
I figured after a very, very, um, stressful day of coaching my BBL, uh, baseball team.
Um, I figured it was time to do some late night fishing.
Um, that was an incredibly stressful day.
My backyard baseball league, what do you mean my what team?
Were you not watching my last stream?
It was two hours ago!
But, it was incredibly stressful coaching my, my, my backyard baseball league team.
When the entire team was literally carried by one tiny girl.
Did you take the kids out for pizza?
Kids?
You mean kid out for pizza?
If anybody deserved a pizza, it's that one child on my team that literally had the entire fucking children on her fucking back.
Not even, you mean my wind trader?
You mean that fuck that couldn't hit a single fucking, a single hit?
None of my children had a home run.
At best, Angela and Jacinda had double.
Oh my god, Pablo was an inside job.
Pablo was a goddamn inside job.
Also, um, funny thing about that stream, um, the devs, the devs that did the remake or slash port to Steam.
I don't know what it's called.
What is it even called?
Is it like a remade or a port?
Anyway, um, the devs that, uh, did the port to Steam actually DM'd me on Twitter after the stream and said they were watching my stream.
I'm sorry.
I did not mean to yell at the children.
But they deserved it.
Maybe if they weren't so fucking bad at baseball, I wouldn't be yelling at the kids.
Anyway, I'm sorry.
Except for Angela, she's great.
You're doing great, sweetie.
Except for Angela, she's doing great.
Anyway.
They are kids.
It doesn't matter.
Children have been fucking training for the Olympics since they are kids.
You think Michael Phelps hasn't been training since he was a child?
Like, this is real.
This is literally champion of the universe.
Like, it's fucking high stakes.
Like, even if they're children, they should not be slacking off because this is a real sport.
It's serious.
Anyway, as I was saying, the devs of Backyard Baseball, not the one who did the port to Steam, actually DMed me on Twitter and was saying how much they enjoyed the stream.
So, like, is it really my fault if I'm getting enabled right now?
Anyway, as I was saying, they said they enjoyed the stream and they wanted to give out keys to the community.
So, I won't be getting the keys tomorrow.
I won't be getting the keys tomorrow.
And I guess, like, what is my stream tomorrow?
I don't even remember what I'm streaming.
Oh, it's a collab.
Never mind.
I'll be giving away the keys on the Silent Hill stream.
So, that gives me time to stall a little bit.
So, I'll be giving away keys for Backyard Baseball at the end of the Silent Hill stream.
So, you guys gotta stick to the end if you guys want free copies of Backyard Baseball.
Well, it's not stalling because I'm doing it at the end.
You actually got endorsed to yell at children?
Thank you for the super chat, Mehdi.
Thank you.
I never get punished, I told you.
And this is why I'll never learn.
Mehdi, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Coyote, thank you for the super chat.
This game is so awesome, Doki.
We hope you enjoyed it.
Yeah, I heard a lot of really good things about this game.
Because, like, everybody's been playing it.
And there's like 4,000 plus reviews right now.
Basically, we're just gonna be fishing.
We need to relax now after a very stressful day coaching uncoachable children.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
TastyDiaz, thank you for the super chat.
Hi, Doki.
Been waiting for a Good Night Dragons to ask this.
But is it possible to add a thick black or white outline to your model to improve visibility?
I am legally blind and it can be hard to see the model at times.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
I think I might do that for certain games.
I tend to not add it because, like...
Actually, I think you need a plug-in for that.
I need to download an OBS plug-in.
I don't know if I could do it right now.
Because I need to restart my OBS to have a plug-in for it.
But I have seen other VTubers also use it before.
But I think it's definitely very situational regarding...
Because I saw Mint using it for her cookie stream.
Like, baking cookie stream.
And it really does look really cute in certain cases.
Like, how it looks on the skin suit.
But I'm definitely down to do it in the future.
Because it looks really nice.
I think right now it would be a great opportunity to use it because I blend in.
I really do blend in with the background very much.
Like, it's literally the same color palette.
So, like, I can see why it would be helpful.
But right now...
But like I said, I can't really do it at the moment.
Because I have to restart my OBS.
But yeah, thank you for the superchat.
Thank you, thank you.
But definitely we'll think about it in the future.
And for future streams.
Alright.
I guess I'll create my own lobby.
Code only.
Alright, let's go.
Let's have a...
We can have 12 dragoons fish with me.
Alright, let's go.
Basically, it's just a nice relaxing fishing stream.
Oh, I can customize.
Wait, I can't?
Am I just...
Oh, that's me.
Wait, what's the...
Right click to zoom in the camera.
Oh, okay.
Oh, it's like mini Animal Crossing.
Oh, so cute.
Okay, and then run.
Oh, that's cute.
Where's my code?
Tab to open the backpack.
There's my fishing rod.
Alright, give me a sec.
Oh, can I customize my...
Can I customize my cat?
Oh, I can be a dog.
But I'm gonna be a dog.
Wait, I wanna be a dog.
Wait, what can I...
Primary color.
Wait, no, I think I like this.
Oh, there we go.
Wait, unless...
Alright, actually...
Yeah, I like this more.
Cause it's like my colors.
And then...
Oh, I can have a different tail!
It's my current tail.
Okay, I want my tail to be up.
Yeah, alright.
This is me.
Oh my god, I can do eyes!
Okay.
Honestly, yeah.
No.
How I feel in the inside.
Another day, another dollar.
Okay, wait.
I feel like this is also me.
But like this...
My team only.
Angela is the only good player on my team.
Post-baseball.
Post-baseball hours right now.
I had Pablo on my team.
Okay, this is actually me.
Okay, I am naked.
I don't have clothes.
That's fine.
What's Blobber?
Red Blobber?
The fuck is Blobber?
Okay, I'll never know what Blobber is.
Alright.
When your fishing rod is out, hold click to charge and release.
Wait, hold click?
Okay.
I got it.
Hold left click to charge and...
Oh, okay.
And then I can...
Press B to open to check how much bait you have.
I have five bait.
Okay, press E to interact and buy bait.
No, I don't want to buy anything.
Catch and sell fish to leave the tutorial.
Oh, it's tutorial.
Oh, you guys can't join because I have to learn the game first.
Is there anything else?
Alright, let's go.
Let's fish.
Am I fishing?
Oh, okay.
Alright.
Okay.
Alright, I'm mashing.
I think I'm mashing.
Do I just have to mash?
Oh my god, do I have to mash left click?
I rather mash space bar.
Oh shit, I got catfish!
Okay, can I sell it?
Interact.
Oh my god, I'm rich!
I did it!
I caught a fish and I sold it!
Alright.
Alright, read.
Oh, I got a claim.
Nice.
I got cosmetics.
I can have a vending machine?
For catcher's luck, speed adult drinks hook literally just beer for those special occasion and lose your buzz.
Oh, to drink.
Guys.
There you go.
Guys, see?
There's a drink for everything.
Beer o'clock.
There's a drink for everything, guys!
What the fuck?
Where did I go?
Where am I?
Oh, there I am.
How do you guys...
Wow, just like real fishing, guys.
Oh my god, there's like so much more to this than I expected.
Wait, that's it.
Never mind.
Alright, let's see.
How do I open?
Alright, guys.
This is my lobby code.
I'll boost up the sound a little bit and also I'll play some lo-fi too.
Give me a sec.
I'll play some nice relaxing music while we relax.
Alright.
Free copyright.
Free lo-fi.
Oh my god, you guys are all...
Guys, where's your customization, guys?
Oh my god.
You guys all look like normies.
Alright, here we go.
Alright, it's relaxing time.
Alright, let's go.
It's time to fish, guys.
We're all fishing time.
Alright.
Nice.
Did you guys see the lunchly thing?
The lunchly being filled with mold?
That's my topic for today.
Guys, fish time.
It's fish time, guys.
Yeah.
That's crazy.
The moldy cheese.
Yeah, I thought I was...
Guys.
Guys, you're taking away all the fish, guys.
What the fuck?
What did you catch?
What?
Wait, I just started.
We just started.
And I caught this.
Okay, guys.
You guys...
Oh, it's a koi!
Wait, it's a koi.
Wait, koi...
Oh, I got ranked up.
Koi is expensive.
Okay.
Don't worry, guys.
But yeah, apparently...
The fuck did you just bring?
My game is broken already.
Who caught this?
Who...
What the fuck did you catch?
Drake.
Oh my god.
What?
Guys, you're taking...
Guys, you're taking all the fish, guys.
Guys, you're taking all...
God.
Guys.
Press G?
Oh, I can bark.
I drowned.
I...
How the fuck?
How are you guys getting so much fish?
Okay, maybe if I fish out here...
Maybe I'll get more fish.
That's enough fish for everyone.
I should might as well just stop fishing.
Christian, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Yeah, thank you for the...
Thank you for letting me know about...
I can bark.
Swanky, welcome to tomato farm.
Welcome, welcome.
Anyway.
Like I said...
The reason why the cheese was moldy...
Was because apparently...
They bragged about how lunchly cheese is made out of...
Oh shit.
Give me a sec.
This is more important.
Sorry guys.
This is way more important.
Oh my god.
I wish I could just...
Come on.
Give me that fish.
Sorry.
This is much more important right now.
Yes.
What did I get?
Why is it so tiny?
Oh wait.
I'm rich.
Never mind.
Why are they all so tiny?
No.
Some YouTuber made a video.
Some YouTuber made a video about how they were comparing lunchly to Lunchables.
And then...
And then the thing is MrBeast, KSI, and Logan Paul all bragged about how lunchly is different from Lunchables.
Because they don't use preservatives for their cheese or food in general.
And because they don't use preservatives, the cheese ended up becoming moldy.
And like...
And it's like...
And then apparently in the reviews, everybody...
All the parents were complaining.
And it's not like a one-time thing too.
It was like...
It was not even a one-time thing.
Parents were complaining all over on the review sites that the Lunchables...
Were filled with mold.
And I was like...
How the...
How the fuck did that like...
There's no way that passed like food safety laws.
Like there's no way that passed the...
What is it called?
FDA?
Or whatever.
Because like...
That's so...
Okay, here you go.
I'll show you a picture.
It's so disgusting.
It's actually...
Oh my god.
I was like watching a video of it.
And I was like...
It's so nasty.
It actually is.
But here's like a tweet of it.
How is...
Guys, you took all the fish, guys.
You actually took all the fish.
I have not had a single bite.
Yeah,
but there's no way...
Oh shit!
Okay, sorry.
Oh, and then I can hold afterwards.
Oh my...
I'm so fucking stupid.
Okay, now I can hold afterwards.
Oh my god.
Yeah, like...
Please, I'm eating dinner.
I'm sorry you had to learn like this.
So I was like...
So I'm just like...
But it doesn't matter.
Because they hit the point where all of them...
They're at a point in their lives where like...
They can't get cancelled.
Because at that point, they're just way too big to be cancelled at that point.
There's like...
And in the end, it ended up giving them more publicity.
Even though it's so fucked up.
People are all talking about them now.
But like...
It ended up making them...
Blowing them up even more.
And now people are like, you know...
Wanting to buy Lunchly to be like...
There's no way.
There's no way they're like...
There's no way it's mold.
People are buying Lunchly to be like...
Is there actually mold?
Oh my god, that's such a cute design though.
That's actually so cute.
Because like...
If Logan Paul could never get...
Could never...
Like still has a career after...
500 controversies.
There's no way for him to like...
There's no way for him to like, you know...
Get actually cancelled.
You got no bait.
I don't need bait to fish.
Look at that.
Fishes are still...
Oh wait, nevermind.
Maybe I should...
Nevermind.
Maybe I do need bait.
JK.
Give me a sec.
Maybe I need...
Wait, can I steal your bait?
I'm interested.
The buddy isn't yours.
Who the fuck are these many fishermen?
Wait, I gotta buy bait, guys.
Give me a sec.
Alright.
Bait restocked.
Worm bait refilled.
Did I refill it?
How much bait do I have?
Oh, I have five.
Okay.
Alright.
It's fine.
Lanty, thank you for the...
Thank you for the one gifted ship.
I'm gonna steal your fish.
Some people explicitly buy...
Yeah, yeah.
But like...
But I don't think children are supposed to...
Who?
Who was it?
I'm gonna see your name.
What's your name?
Which...
Oh, I got the fish anyway.
Who was it?
I remember what you looked like.
Which wolf are you?
It was you.
It was...
You don't think I...
You think I don't...
I was...
Explain yourself.
What?
I can apologize right now or you get kicked.
I swear.
Wait, was it you?
I'm sorry.
You...
I saw...
Wait a minute.
Who was it?
Actually, I don't actually remember.
It was either...
It was...
I'm gonna...
I'm gonna remember who it was after the stream is over.
One of you.
I will remember one of you.
After...
After the stream is over.
I swear to god.
I swear to...
Oh my god, there's beer.
There's beer.
How the fuck did he get over there?
How the fuck did that guy get over there?
But yeah, no, it's actually...
The fucking mold shit is actually...
I see you, Mudd.
I fucking see you.
Anyway...
But yeah, it's just insane that they're able to...
They're able to get away with the fact that like...
Who the fuck invited this alien dog here?
Who, you freak?
Why do you have four eyes, you fucking freak?
Anyway...
We're conformists here, okay?
There's no individualists here, guys.
Anyway, as I was saying...
But yeah, the moldy cheese thing...
Is actually...
Oh my god, wait.
Oh my god, it's fishing time.
The moldy cheese thing is actually insane.
Just to read about...
Or like watch the video.
It's just disgusting.
And I bet you they're not...
They're just gonna be like...
Oh...
Oh, like...
Oh, it's just a one-time thing.
But there's like reviews of it everywhere.
Being like it's not a one-time thing.
Because they don't have preservatives.
They don't have preserve...
That's right.
We're...
Sorry.
Rainbow, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Prime is an energy drink.
No matter how you slice it.
That's terrible for kids.
It even stays for people above...
Yeah, it's for like kids above 14.
But Lunchly is like...
Clearly marketed towards...
Towards children.
Like actually children.
So it's like...
What the...
I don't know.
I don't understand.
But it doesn't matter.
Because they're still gonna have a platform.
Like...
So many creators got cancelled.
But a lot of them still continue to have a platform.
As long as they keep streaming.
Pretending nothing bad is happening.
That's what I...
This is what like...
Being a content creator.
The best advice I can...
Like a content creator can do.
When you're in a controversy.
Is just to ignore what's going on.
And just keep streaming.
Because like...
There's nothing else you can do.
So like...
If you just keep streaming.
It doesn't like...
Just keep streaming.
It doesn't matter.
Like...
Okay, the fucking...
That MoonMoon shit.
That fucking...
The MoonMoon and his GoonVentures.
When it fucking become public.
He actually became a bigger streamer.
My god.
He actually...
He actually became a bigger...
Like he had more people watching him afterwards.
It was crazy.
And he's just...
And he just like played along with it.
I was like looking at the titles of his like Twitch stream.
And it was just like...
Goon Goon is here.
I'm just like...
Oh my god.
And he became a bigger streamer.
More people were watching him.
Cause he's just like...
Well, there's nothing else I can do.
So I'm just gonna keep...
I'm just gonna keep streaming.
Goon Goon blew up.
That's a dead poll.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Oh my god.
I got a little crayfish.
Look at me go.
What was the room code?
I think it's full now.
Cause like you can only have 12 people in a room.
Right?
I can't tell.
I don't remember if that was the case.
But this was the room code.
I'm pretty sure you can...
But that's being a content creator.
You just keep going.
There's nothing else you can do.
You just...
You just keep streaming.
Cause like...
Even if people are trying to cancel you.
Like...
You still want a career.
Just keep streaming.
And then...
And then like...
Somebody will still watch you.
I mean it's true.
Somebody will still watch you somehow.
I have no bait.
God damn it.
Why do I can only buy 5 baits?
Like...
I don't...
I'm gonna put this in my aquarium.
I don't need to sell.
Wait.
If I...
Can I donate it to the aquarium only?
There's an upgrade?
Wait.
How do I upgrade?
What did I get?
I don't even know what...
I didn't read it.
How do I upgrade?
Go in the cabin?
Which one?
There's so many cabins.
This one?
Oh, this cabin.
Oh, it's a hub.
Oh my god.
Okay.
Upgrades.
Increase rod power.
There's...
Unlock the...
Oh, wait.
I can upgrade the camp.
I might as well just upgrade the camp.
I'm just gonna upgrade the camp.
And then...
Wait, I wanna...
Oh, I don't have money right now.
Wait.
Let me...
Let me see if I can...
Go here.
And then...
Oh my god.
What the fuck?
Wait.
Insert my fish?
Oh, I have to hold it.
Wait.
Are these other people's fishes?
Jesus Christ.
What the fuck?
What the...
Holy...
Oh my god.
Okay, that's a giant ass fish.
Okay.
Nevermind.
Let's...
I guess I'm just gonna sell my fish.
Fuck it.
You guys can donate to the...
What the fuck?
Where's the head?
I can't even see the head.
I'm just gonna sell everything.
Fuck this.
This is...
My camp is more important.
Alright.
Wait.
What does she do?
Oh, she gives me...
Oh my god.
There's no way.
There's...
Way numbers.
No way.
No fucking way.
There's...
Oh my god.
Okay.
Okay, what?
10 out of 10 game right there.
No, I wanna be naked.
Also, like, all the...
Oh my god, I wanna be cool!
Wait, so cool?
Wait, silly guy?
Just a silly little guy.
Oh my god, wait!
I have instruments!
You can have a tambourine!
That's so cute!
Okay.
Oh, so that's like the...
People were buying fish water buddies.
Wait, I can hit people?
Wait a minute.
Say less.
How do I equip this?
It's fucking right.
Oh my god.
Okay.
Wait, this is perfect.
Wait a minute.
How do I...
I wanna place this...
Wait, one.
Okay, there we go.
Wait, okay.
I want to...
Okay.
This is perfect.
I know exactly what I'm gonna do.
So, like, how do I buy better...
How do I buy more bait?
Oh, from 10!
There we go.
350.
Okay.
Alright, this is it.
Alright, we're filled.
Alright, let's go.
I know what I wanna do.
What the fuck?
Are you guys fucking having...
Are you guys having...
Connections on my camp?
Are you guys...
What was this?
What were those hearts, huh?
Oh, yeah, I would like a whale.
Yeah, nevermind.
Oh my God!
Wait, is that the whale?
Wait, wait, give me.
Give me.
How do I have it?
I want it.
If I can...
Oh my God, if I can sell it.
Wait.
Give it to me.
How do I take this?
Are you e-dating in my fishing game?
Were you two e-dating in my fishing game?
Guys.
We're all here to be alone right now, guys.
We're all...
Guys.
Alright, let's...
Oh, people can give me fish?
Oh, yes.
Fish.
Oh my God.
That's so many fishes.
Okay, wait.
Let's see.
Alright.
Wait, I wanna see...
Wait, where is my...
Was it this?
Holy shit.
Massive...
Oh my God!
I can't even move!
This is how slow I move!
Oh my...
Okay, here we go.
We're taking it over.
We're gonna bring it over.
Oh my God.
Thousand...
Guys, okay.
Here we go.
It's time.
We're gonna upgrade our camp, guys.
Our camp is gonna be beautiful!
Yay!
A new private island prop and additional items in the shop.
A new private island prop?
What's the private island prop?
Oh, I guess I get to have more bait.
Oh, wait.
I want better bait then.
Okay.
Increase rod.
Oh, I should get this.
And then, I'll get better bait.
And then, also my rod power, my rod speed.
I'll just upgrade everything!
I'm fucking rich right now!
Chance of higher...
Chance of catching treasure.
Chance to not consume bait.
Wait, I might want treasure.
Wait, treasure is better.
Wait, the...
Oh my God, the sunglasses!
I almost forgot.
Okay.
A romantic gift for someone or yourself.
Okay, where is it?
Where's the...
Oh, there.
Okay.
Oh my God, I'm gonna be so cool!
Alright, where is it?
Where is it?
Oh my...
I'm so cool.
I'm so fucking cool now.
Alright, now that...
Okay, let's see.
What else do I want?
I have so much money.
Let's see.
Where is it?
Where?
What do I want?
Okay.
Oh my God!
I should get...
Wait, what is this?
What is this?
Oh my God, there's so many shit to buy.
I don't know what to buy.
Let's see.
I should get a...
I should get a hat!
Wait, all these hats suck.
Nevermind, I shouldn't get a hat.
Nevermind, I just wanna be cool.
Alright, let's see.
Might as well just be more lucky...
And then...
Get treasure.
Maybe...
Oh, wait!
I gotta get a little buddy!
The little buddy can fish for me!
Oh my God.
And then get better bait.
Here we go.
Alright, guys.
Everything is gonna...
Everything is gonna go well now.
Wait, nobody's fishing anymore.
What the fuck?
Why is nobody fishing in my fishing game?
What?
Where are the fishermen in my fishing game?
I don't understand.
Guys, thank you for the super chat!
Thank you, thank you!
Greetings from a lab.
Your stream...
Oh, your stream is currently being run on the same computer...
That are 600k equipment is...
You know what?
Good for...
This is the type of content your lab needs.
Is everybody E-Dating in my fucking fishing server?
Guys, no E-Dating allowed!
We're all here to fish!
And also beat people up.
No E-Dating allowed!
Oh, shit!
Okay.
Guys, no E-Dating allowed in my fishing game.
Guys.
We're all here to be alone right now and fish.
This is goodnight, dragoons.
Alright.
Get them away from...
If I see you guys...
Oh, if I see you guys E-Dating right now...
I'm gonna...
Oh...
Oh, somebody...
Oh, you two are...
Are you two E-Dating?
Leave!
Get out!
No E-Dating!
No E-Dating allowed!
Get out!
Separate!
Separate right now!
You guys are not a couple!
Leave!
Get out!
Get...
Separate!
Stop being...
No touchy!
You gotta leave space for Jesus in the middle!
Guys!
Like, what...
Like, what the nuns say?
Leave space for Jesus in the middle!
Remember when you're slow dancing?
You make sure you're like...
You have, like, your arm length away?
That's it!
That's the thing!
Oh, I swear to God...
I swear to God...
Oh, get out!
Get out!
I will drown you!
I...
Get...
I will...
I will make sure there's no E-Daters.
There's no E-Daters.
There's no cuddling around...
In the...
In the Doki Bird server.
Alright.
Here we go.
This is it.
We're back to fishing.
This is a...
Fish only server here.
Fish only server.
Dragoons together strive.
Dave, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
What the fuck?!
32?!
What do I upgrade for that?
That was 32!
Oh my god, okay, obviously we're not maybe we'll do this like What the fuck do I do in that situation?
All right, we're gonna put this guy here.
He's just a little guy.
Oh, thank god.
All of you guys are separated All right, we're gonna put worms.
I realized I need to upgrade broad power, but I did not have that Oh, the bride is in the super chat.
Thank you.
Doki Bride has become That old woman in the sims who would attack couples showing public affections on dates in community lots Thank you for the super chat, thank you.
And I will do it again That's right if I see you guys If I don't see any distance between you guys Oh, I swear I'm gonna check i'm gonna check back here.
I swear to god if I see If I see any oh Oh, if I see anybody out here that doesn't put six feet in between each other.
Oh
Oh Oh you guys are gonna get it you guys Back to fishing, uh platonic server only It's a pg server here they give the super chat.
Thank you.
Uh, two dogs.
Uh, they give a super chat Thank you.
Thank you.
Uh, w mercy.
They give a super chat.
Thank you.
This is what happens when you stream Um aura, thank you for the super chat.
No maidens.
No maidens allowed guys No maidens allowed.
This is a christian server.
We're here to fish and only fish All right, anyway, where was I Where was I?
Oh, yeah, I was talking about like, um, I was talking about lunch lady that shit was actually so crazy um Oh, yeah
I really want to show you guys some sneak peeks of some of the things i'm working on But first i'll let me fish real quick Yay What did I get?
Did I get Oh, I got another goldfish nice, let's go anyway, um, so we're gonna have uh Just start dating the fish problem solved mr. Stan.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Thank you Uh, let me stay.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
What about bromance?
Is that allowed?
No romances are allowed On this island.
This is a fishing only island The only romance you're gonna get is between you and the fish when you catch it All right.
Anyway, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Thank you affiliate.
I'm thinking of a super chat.
Thank you Fish wants her couple's fear.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Thank you This is you you put your fucking romance at the desk because out here we are Fishing if you let any romance into your heart, that means you were never committed to the art of fishing You were never committed to this Anyway, here we go.
By the way Romance will only get in the way of our true passion fishing Oh shit, look at that.
I got a massive walleye And I found a coin back too Okay, but can I kiss?
Okay, whatever you do with the fish it's on you Equazo, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Thank you um, the The only hookups you need are those at the end of your fishing life That's basically it he said what what we were all thinking anyway, um One of the things I want to show you guys so you guys know how i'm getting a line Um, so one of the things i'm working on at the moment Um with the with an art with the artist who did the intro is that i'm working on animated line stickers that i'm planning on selling online and i'm super excited because they just sent me the Uh,
these just sent me the uh animation Uh sketches of it and oh my god, i'll show you i'll give you guys a sneak peek Chat i'm gonna i'm gonna give you guys a sneak peek for like two of them because it looks so cute Um, it's still a work in progress.
I'm gonna head back first.
I'm gonna head back and watch the other people Go fishing All right Where are you guys?
All right You guys better you guys better be whoa Oh That's right, you think I don't know separate separate Separate there we go.
There we go.
That's right.
You think I wouldn't know you think I wouldn't know you think I wouldn't know that you guys decided to To to be close after I left, huh?
I'll be here supervising now
Oh, I didn't even notice likely story was that say I Okay
Get out get out of get out of this server get get out of the server And make sure there's space in between you two Get oh my god.
Look what you did.
Look what you did to coyote.
This is your fault All right Don't worry.
I'm gonna make sure oh my god.
Why can't I?
I'm gonna make sure okay.
There we go.
Everybody is fine.
Okay, there we go Everybody is okay now.
Oh, whoa.
Whoa.
What's going on here?
Yeah, what what is this romance doing here?
All right, there we go.
There we go Supervision complete I am like the I am like the supervisor at christian camp What's going on here what's going on here?
I am the supervisor of christian camp there is there I there is no no closeness here.
Okay, that's fine.
That's fine Um, i'm the sunday school teacher right now.
Anyway, let me let me grab it real quick.
I'm super excited.
I'm also commissioning extra um animated stickers Um that i'll be giving up um away for free for everybody Um, so like you guys get like paid versions, but like it's not me a lot the free versions just like maybe like a three to four uh, three to four anime stickers that'll be releasing for free and then the others would be like a paid stickers that Uh,
you have to buy online, but let me let me grab it real quick
Oh my god, it's so cute.
I'm super happy.
Uh, there's gonna be a text on it too But like these are like work in progresses too.
So they're not done yet Um, let me see if it works on Wait, does it work if I put it as an image?
Because it's like a png.
Is it animated?
No, it's not Ah, it's not animated Oh my god, it doesn't work as an animation wait, does it work if I do it as I don't know if it doesn't work if I do it as a uh media source, let me see create new Let me see if it works as a media source.
No, it doesn't exist as a media source Okay, i'm gonna give you guys the link to it then Uh, let me see again.
Can you guys access this link?
Wait, let me check.
Let me check the perms.
Oh anyone with a link.
Okay.
I'm gonna give you guys the link to it.
Um Me oh shit me thank you for the akasupa.
Thank you.
Thank you Wait, what's this?
What's this?
Just because I was gone for one second Just just because I was gone for what get whoa, whoa, whoa sit away away Away, this is a christian server away.
Oh shit.
I got a large crappy Nice, okay All right here to interact here to Here to supervise again.
Um, let me give you guys a link to it.
It's so cute Uh, but this is a work in progress of the animated stickers That's being worked on at the animated line stickers that's being worked on at the moment And i'm super excited because uh, it's i'm super excited because it looks so good
One will be Um, the the second one is good morning Um, there's gonna be a text that says good morning.
And the other the first one is gonna be like, okay I think it was like good job or okay.
Um So i'm not sure I don't remember but i'm super excited and another one is that the Dragoons reference sheet is gonna be done soon.
So, um the one I posted on twitter the one that everybody uses um is um It's actually the incomplete version of the reference sheet Um, but the artist has finally finished like the extra illustration.
So like the extra ones has like lore and stuff to it so, um I it's I love it.
It's so cute.
I honestly Um, because I gave like certain things I really wanted in the reference sheet and i'm super excited Um when it's finally complete complete when she puts everything together or when they put everything together so Basically, i'll explain the lore.
Um so basically, uh Um, the first one the first one on the top left is that well It's not lore lore, but it's more so of like the top left is that uh, basically dragoons can be any color But the default color is the yellow the pastel yellow so you can customize your dragoon in any way you like i'll also add like Um,
i'll also be providing like line art so people who can't draw can just color in their dragoon really quick Um, and then the second one the one with the tomato tomato goon would be like Uh dragoons can have like certain mutations uh can have certain mutations um for uh On how they look like so sometimes maybe they turn out into a freak of nature and become a tomato.
Um the third one is that Uh, there's attack there's passive mode dragoons and attack so like, you know Where you guys tuck in your legs and everything and then there's like attack mode dragoons where you you know legs extend and then uh the fourth one is basically uh the fourth one is that uh Some say dragoons were evolved from dragons
Some say their ancestors were actually Dinos or dragons and then the the last one is basically like everybody bullies the iggoons.
Everybody bullies the iggoons.
That's lore.
It's true.
Any iggoons in chat?
Show yourself.
Oh, I see you.
Tuxedo cat, why are you laughing?
Tuxedo cat, why the fuck you laughing?
You're an iggoon yourself.
Acceptable.
I like how one of the iggoons just started laughing.
I'm like, why are you laughing?
You're one of them.
No, not iggoon.
No.
Apparently, one of them really likes it.
So like, he's winning right now.
What is this?
Just cuz?
What the fuck?
Why are you in the air?
Okay, get it.
All right, separate.
Separate.
This guy's in the air.
Separate right now.
Anyway.
Oh, wait, is he bugged?
Oh, shit.
Well, even if he's bugged, even if he's bugged, it doesn't exempt you from e-dating.
Iggoon spotted.
Why are you saying that, Katis?
You're gonna be an iggoon next month, Katis.
Yeah.
You think I don't know?
You're gonna be an iggoon next month.
Remember what you said because the iggoons are gonna remember.
Just you wait.
So I'm super excited about that.
I'm checking out like all the stuff I need, like all the stuff I wrote down that I wanted to talk about because I wrote down I wrote down a lot of stuff.
Oh, yeah, this is what I wanted to talk about for a while.
This is what I wanted to talk about.
Basically, did you guys, okay, you guys hear about the Pokemon leaks?
Okay, so like I know I'm late to the party, but I've been like wanting to talk about that.
Okay, I see.
Oh, you think, oh, just because you're an alien, you think I'm gonna let you e-date the others?
Just because you're from this planet, you think you're exempt from the culture of e-dating?
Oh, just... It doesn't, oh, it doesn't matter.
It doesn't matter if you're not from this planet.
It doesn't matter.
You're in our world.
You gotta know the rules.
The law applies to everybody.
You're in the server.
The law still applies to you.
I saw those hearts.
No hearts allowed.
This is a serious fishing day.
But yeah, no, apparently, my favorite, my favorite part was like all the artwork and stuff related to the Pokemon leaks.
Wait, let me, I think I like, oh, this one's my favorite.
This is one of my favorite.
The Typhlosion slander.
Oh my god, the Typhlosion slander is so fucking funny.
Like all the artists were like, please, please leave him alone.
Please.
He has, they have nothing.
They have nothing.
Um, it had nothing to do with this.
My boy did nothing wrong.
And then apparently, the reason, okay, for the reason why, um, apparently in the end, the leaks, the Typhlosion shit was like super mistranslated, um, because like, um, the, because it was like done by like machine translation.
So because of that, a lot of the story that like, like an actual Japanese person translated the story, it was not as bad as we thought it was.
The Pokemon still banged a person, but like, it was still like mixed, you know, still so bad because, you know, human Pokemon relationship, but it was not as bad as we thought it was bad.
It was so bad, but I like how they're like, they're like, oh my god.
They're like, it's not that bad, but it's still bad.
It's...
Like, it's still a Pokemon human relationship, but it wasn't that bad.
So, um, um, but like, and then like, the other like, wait, why are you guys sitting next to each other?
You guys, wait, I will, either you guys separate right now, or I'll force you two to separate.
Guys, guys, you don't, you don't want me to get involved, guys.
Guys, you don't want me to get involved.
That's right, there we go.
There we go.
That's right, that's how you keep space in between, guys.
You gotta keep space in between.
A child appeared.
Where did the child come from?
Whoa, whoa.
Leave room for Arceus.
Anyway, what the fuck?
Why are three of you on?
This is a two minimum.
This is a maximum two-person bench.
Okay, there we go.
Oh, there we go.
That's much better.
That is so much better.
Anyway, as I was saying, um, as I was saying, um, and then the other really crazy leak was the whole origin of the universe shit.
Like, somebody, one of the leaks from the Pokemon leaks was basically, was basically, like, um, the whole story of how the universe, the Pokemon universe was made.
That's crazy.
There's so much deep lore with Pokemon, but, like, they don't release any of it.
Like, and there's so much, there's so much world building, and they can make an actual Pokemon Bible.
No, you're right.
They can literally make a Pokemon Bible, but it's all locked up in the company.
Like, I'm, like, why, like, I get they're, like, making this so, like, artists know what to do or something, or, like, they know how to build the game or stuff, but, like, but, like, I, I don't understand.
They could have actually, they could have actually, like, done so much with that lore, like, and the world building and everything, but it's just so cookie cutter now.
Um, it's just so, also the fucking, did you guys see the Pokemon designs?
The, okay, the, the scary monster Pokemon designs that they, like, that was, like, behind the scenes concept art that did not look like Pokemon art.
That shit was wild.
Oh my, wait, let me see if I can find it.
Pokemon design, um, concept art scary.
It was so fucking scary, like, where Catern was apparently, like, what Catern looked like, and I was like, oh my god, who drew, who drew this?
Oh my god.
Like, it's actually, like, this actually goes so hard, like, I was like, because this is what Catern was supposed to look like, like, holy shit, that was what Catern was supposed to look like.
Look at him, look at, look at that fucking freak.
Hmm, it looks, it looks crazy.
Um, um, but yeah, sadly, Typhlosion has now become the Vaporeon meme.
Like, um, um, but yeah, that's, whoa, yeah, that's actually, uh, I mean, like, you know, Vaporeon has had it rough for years now, so, like, you know, like, it's somebody else's turn, like, and unfortunately, Typhlosion had to be the one to go.
It was Typhlosion's, it was somebody's turn.
Vaporeon has been at it for a long time, and now, now it's Typhlosion's turn.
Like, we needed another person, we need, we needed another, another, another Pokmon to, to go through the same thing now.
Um, it's a new generation, but poor, like, you know, the Zoomers had to have a new one.
It doesn't need a copypasta.
The company made the copy, the company made it.
Like, at that point, like, the company itself gave us the...
They gave us, they handed it to us at that point.
We don't need to create our own, they literally just handed it to us.
Um, oh, but I think this one's my, I think, like, the Pastel Zigzagoon was really cute.
I don't know if you guys saw the, um, the past, the, like, the beta pixel art of Pokmon, but the, ah, the Pastel one was, the Pastel Zigzagoon was so fucking cute.
I wish that was, I wish that was what the actual design looked like in the end.
Um, all right, what else did I want to talk about today?
Oh my god, I wish I could, I, god, I hate coughing so much.
I think that the worst part about getting sick is just the non-stop coughing.
Um, it's just such a pain.
Ah, I want to do so much, I want to do so much, but the coughing is just fucking killing me sometimes.
Um, but all I can do, like, like, even if I rest, it doesn't matter because it's more so of, like, like, it just goes away in the end.
It goes away in the end, it doesn't, like, like, it doesn't matter how much I rest.
I just need to wait, like, it, at one point, it's just gonna go away.
Um, it's basically the aftermath of my cold.
Um, but, um, there's nothing I could do about, like, uh, fixing it faster.
It's just a waiting game.
Uh, oh yeah, by the way, when I had, like, no internet, um, I heard the craziest fucking rant, um, in the, in the apartment lobby, and it was so fucking crazy.
So, like, um, you know, I was, like, mooching off the wi-fi at the lobby at the, my apartment complex.
I was mooching off the wi-fi because that was, like, the only place that, where the wi-fi worked.
So I brought my, like, foot, I went downstairs, and then, like, while sitting down, um, there was this other lady that was, like, close by talking to this other stranger.
Like, they don't know each other.
And then she was, like, talking about how, um, how the RCMP was out to get her.
And I was, like, what the fuck?
And she was going on about how, like, um, yeah, like, I'm going through so much shit.
And, like, oh my god, the RCMP is out to get me.
Like, I, when I was, like, bro, what?
Like, the Mounties?
I was, like, like, I was just, like, like, specifically the Mounties, by the way.
Like, what's the RCMP?
The RCMP is, like, the Canadian Royal Police.
Um, so, like, they're known for wearing the red jackets and, like, riding on horses and the little, like, the little, like, fucking, um, Pharrell Williams hat.
Um, but yeah, they're, like, the Royal Canadian Mounted Police.
But I was just listening to this, like, um, I guess, like, housewife or house lady, I don't know, um, talking about how, how she thinks she's being monitored by the RCMP and how she, like, thinks that they're doing everything they can to, like, get her.
And I'm, like, holy shit, like, this lady lives in my apartment building.
I was just, like, oh my god, bro.
Nikita, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Joke's gonna be on you when a squad of Mounties are raiding your building.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
And I was just, like, and I was just, like, I didn't want to, like, like, you know, I wanted to move away, but I also didn't want to move away because I was, like, what else is she gonna talk about?
Like, and then, apparently, she was, like, talking about how she's, like, in the, she's, like, in a category for, like, national, like, risk of national security.
And all I could think about was, like, who are you?
I don't know if she's actually crazy or, like, like, that's, like, legit because she's, like, oh yeah, no, okay, the most, oh my god, she was, like, saying how, like, yeah, okay, okay, like, I, I was, I was a little freaked out because the, it was crazy because,
like, I was a little freaked out because she was saying how, like, yeah, they took away my kid because, like, I'm, I'm, like, put in a category that's, like, threat to national security.
And then I was, like, excuse me?
And I was, like, you were able to rent an apartment here?
This is a very expensive place and you somehow were able to rent an apartment here?
I was, like, what?
And then, and then she went on to talk about how, like, the RCP is all together, like, everything.
I was, like, how did you pass the background check to, like, be here?
I, I was so surprised.
I was, like, there's no way you, there's no way you passed the background, background check to fucking rent here.
The rent here is, like, fucking expensive.
The reason why I picked, like, the reason why is that, like, the security-wise reason, by the way, like, the build, like, the place, like, I always pick places that have, like, good security, um, and everything.
And, like, it's also, like, a really nice place.
So I'm just, like, how did, how, how did you get here?
Like, I don't know if you're just, I, I don't know.
I, I, I was, like, oh my god.
And then the other lady, she didn't realize she was talking to somebody like that because the conversation at first was, like, very nice.
Like, they were having a nice conversation about, like, like, you know, like, they were having small talk.
And then, and then the lady started talking about fucking RCMP and, like, like, fucking her daughter taking away from her and stuff because she's a threat to national security.
And then, and then the other lady was just, like, oh wow.
Oh my god.
I think the other lady was just, like, I was just, like, oh, I did not expect the conversation to turn like that, too.
And she's just, like, oh, she, I, she didn't know what to say.
She was just, she just didn't know what to say, like, oh.
And then at the end was, like, well, I hope you get your daughter back.
And I was just, like, oh, oh my god.
And I just, I just laughed at that point.
Like, I think I, like, I heard she was, like, well, I hope you get your daughter back.
And then I just laughed.
I went back to my, I went back to my room.
I went... I didn't know what conversation.
I was, like, oh my god.
I didn't even know what conversation I was overhearing.
Oh my god.
Um, but yeah, um, yeah.
No, don't say that.
I'm not an accomplice.
Please don't say, don't say that.
I don't, I'm scared.
Um, anyway, anyway, um, what else?
No, oh yeah, but by the way, guys, um, I want to really, oh my gosh, next week, I really want to play Sniper Elite, because there's this one part in Sniper Elite that's, this is a game that I've been trying to get perms for in the past, but never could.
And, like, because there was one thing, I've never played Sniper Elite before, but we all know why I want to play this.
We all know why I want to play Sniper Elite.
There's one moment in Sniper Elite that I've always wanted to try, because I've never played that game before.
And, like, I want to...
I want to, I want to play it next week.
I wonder, it's very, it's very infamous for one thing.
So, that's something I'm excited for it, um, next week.
Um, oh, also, uh, voice packs, um, the Halloween voice pack is coming out soon.
We're just making, uh, graphics for it to sell, um, but I'm super duper excited, uh, because, um, um, sound guy just finished editing it.
I'll give you a sneak peek.
I'll give you guys a sneak peek of it.
Um, it'll be, like, a five-second sneak peek anyway, um, but it'll be on sale on the store for, like, uh, I think, like, five dollars.
I think that's, I don't even know how to price voice packs.
Um, and it's gonna come with an exclusive wallpaper, um, that's made just for the sound pack, uh, sorry, voice pack, sorry, made for the voice pack.
Let me play it real quick.
Let me find... I have so many chat messages.
I'll give you guys a sneak peek.
I don't know if you guys can hear it, though.
Um, let me know if you guys can hear this.
Can you guys hear it?
Knock, knock.
Hey, did you forget?
We're supposed to hang out together for Halloween, of course.
Alright, that's it.
That's your sneak peek.
That's your sneak peek, but it comes with a wallpaper that's themed around...
It comes with a wallpaper that's themed around, um, um, around the voice pack, too.
Uh, so yeah, it'll be five dollars, um, and you get a wallpaper.
But, um, it's something I've been... I'm glad I can finally start doing... doing now, um, because, um, because, uh, it's something I've been wanting.
Like, there's, like, a lot of things I can finally do now that things are cooling down and everything.
Also, another update.
Minecraft server.
The docus... I'm sorry it's been dead.
I had so many things going on that this has been a backburner, but the Minecraft dev has finally came back from his vacation... from his business... Sorry, not vacation.
From his business trip, and, uh, we are, uh, we will be implementing the... a huge update to the Doki SMP server where people can finally get automatically whitelisted.
So we stopped whitelisting for a while because, um, it was, uh, there was a lot of stuff going on.
So, um, the server in... I think, like, it'll be either next week or the week after will be closed down to get a few updates going in.
Um, and we're gonna have a Discord server.
Uh, we're gonna have a Discord server that's synced up to your YouTube membership.
So if you're membered, you automatically... you automatically gain access to the server.
And then when you're unmembered, when you lose your membership, you get kicked out of the server automatically.
And the whitelist is synced up to your Discord.
So, like, um, to your Discord slash YouTube membership.
Um, and from there, there's gonna be a lot of things.
You guys can, like, donate specifically to the Doki SMP for updates, for paying the devs, for giving ideas on what you want on there and everything.
We're gonna have a custom resource pack, too, for it in the future.
Um, so all of that is, like, we're gonna have a huge update soon that's coming in.
Um, we're gonna have... and it's gonna be automated.
Like, it's gonna be, like, self-running after that.
After this update, everything will be self-running, so I don't have to, like, um, monitor it.
So, like, as in, like, I don't have to, like, technically be, uh, be, like, the project lead for it anymore after we get all those updates in.
It'll be, like, what's the word called?
Like, self-can, like, what's that word called?
Like, when it's, like, working on its own type deal, so I don't have to, uh, be heavily, like, involved in it.
Self-sufficient, yeah.
The moment all these updates come in, it'll be self-sustain, like, self-sufficient slash self-sustainable.
So, it'll be automated and everything, so, um, I can, like, hop in, not have to worry about, like, um, updates or moderation, because the updates you want, uh, you can, basically, when we get the Discord server, you guys can decide on the next updates,
and then the devs will work with you guys on what the updates would be and everything.
So, like, that's basically how it goes, and you guys have ideas on what you guys want, like, designs and stuff like that.
So, so, like, from there, from there, I don't have to worry about, like, making sure everything goes.
I don't have to make, I don't have to, like, supervise it too much after that.
Um, so, here's, like, a little update on the server.
So, like, what we're adding, um, okay, so, this is what it looks like.
So, we added the PvP Coliseum.
So, there's going to be a PvP Coliseum, um, that's going to be part of the big update, where other dragoons from different, where dragoons from different factions can challenge each other in a fight.
So, you press a button, and you're TP'd into the Coliseum, or TP'd into, like, spectator section, and you can watch dragoons fucking fight each other from different factions.
So, this is, like, one of the big updates that we're putting in.
Um, finally, you guys can, can fight each other.
Like, there's a point in being in factions now.
Um, so, that's one of the big updates we have going in.
Um, I think, like, that's...
Is there anything else I want to talk about?
Uh, I think that's really it.
That's, that's really it.
I think that's, like, most of the stuff that I really wanted to, like, update you guys about in life.
There's a lot of projects going on simultaneously for me, um, so it's, like, um, it's very, like, sometimes it gets very difficult to, like, uh, figure out what the fuck is going on, because I, I'm working on a lot of things simultaneously, um, and stuff,
so, like, I do a lot of things, like, on my own.
I do have a lot of staff and stuff, but, like, there's some things I like to do on my own, just because, like, I'm a perfectionist, and I just like being involved in, like, uh, being involved in the process of making sure, like, everything is going the right way.
So, yeah, it's just a lot of things going on.
I want to fish.
All right, guys.
I'm gonna catch one fish, guys.
I'm gonna catch...
Oh, shit, guys.
I'm gonna catch one fish, everybody.
Watch this.
What happened?
Oh, I have bait.
What do you mean I'm slacking?
I'm not slacking.
I have you guys to fish for me.
This is my island.
You guys gotta pay taxes.
Why else did I create my own server?
I...
Oh, I still got my snail.
Oh, you think I didn't see?
You think I didn't see?
That's fucking right.
Don't make me revoke your fishing privileges.
All right, guys.
This is my private own island.
It's time to pay your taxes.
Give me your fish.
Wait, what's this?
Oh, he's okay.
Give me your fish.
Oh, my god.
Okay.
This is a privately owned corporate island, which requires you to pay your fish tax.
Oh, I want that.
Wait, that's a crocodile.
Give me.
I want that.
That's a gator.
All right, I'm looking at my mail.
I have two mail.
Where are my other letters?
Dragons, where are my letters?
My fish letters.
You already paid in advance?
You think... you think this island is one fish per...
Oh, you thought this island, you only pay one fish per trip?
No, we're charged by hourly.
It's one hour has passed already.
It's two fishes time.
Oh, hey, letter received.
Thank you.
Nice.
All right.
Oh, I got a crab.
Oh, I got a pupfish.
Let's go.
Guys, give me that fucking gator right now or you'll get kicked.
This is a privately owned corporate island.
This is not... this is not for freeloaders, guys.
This is not for freeloaders.
Fish or kick.
Rent is due.
Ring, ring.
The landlord is here.
The landlord is here to claim the rent.
Where the fuck is your hat?
What's your hat?
I need to know.
Wait, what's your hat?
Where the fuck is that hat?
What does it say?
Oh my god, I can never...
Women fear me.
Fish fury.
Men turn their eyes away as I walk.
No piece there make a sound in my presence.
I am alone.
God.
Holy shit.
That fucking hat.
Oh my god.
All right, nice.
Nice, I got my taxes.
See, I don't need a fish.
Why are you fucking sending hearts?
Why are you sending hearts?
Oh, is he bugged out?
Okay, there we go.
All right.
Let's... let's go sell our fish now.
Yippee.
Oh my god, look at this.
What the fuck?
Wait, I'm gonna keep that.
Okay, let's see.
We're gonna get rid of this.
And then I want to keep the crocodile.
Oh, we can't sell the turtle.
They're in danger.
So we'll keep that.
Nice.
Wait, wait, wait, wait.
Wait, how big can I get?
Okay, I want to know.
All right, I want to know how big I can get.
Oh shit, more taxes.
How big can you grow?
Can you grow pretty big?
Am I growing?
No, I stopped growing.
No!
I stopped growing!
Like, what's the point?
What's the point?
Guys, I'm a... guys.
Guys, please don't look at me.
I...
Please don't look at me.
I didn't use any... this is natural.
I didn't use any enhancements, I swear.
This is all natural.
This is all natural growing, I swear to god.
If I keep drinking, maybe I'll get bigger in many ways.
If I...
If I keep drinking, maybe I'll... maybe everything will get big.
Okay.
Wait, wait a minute.
What's going on here?
What would... oh.
Oh, yeah?
Oh, you think running away would stop?
What's going on?
Explain yourself right now.
It's you to explain yourself.
What was it?
Does she mean something to you?
Does she mean anything to you?
Tell me, buds.
Tell me right now.
I'm bigger than you.
Tell me.
Holy shit.
I'm fucking huge.
Tell me right now.
She means everything.
Well, she...
Oh,
I'm gonna...
Buds, it's either you or her.
Choose wisely, buds.
If you love her... if you love her, you would sacrifice yourself for her.
Buds, all I'm saying...
If you love her, would you sacrifice yourself for her or do I kick...
kick her?
Buds, your pick.
No answers means I'll... I'll kick you.
I'll kick you.
Buds, come on.
I'll give you 10 seconds, buds.
Goodbye,
buds.
All right, Lamb.
What do you have to say?
Lamb...
What do you...
Muds sacrificed themselves for you.
What do you have to say?
They picked you over themselves.
That's all you could say?
He chose love and all you could give me is an 0-7?
That's fucked, dude.
That's...
That's so fucked.
He gave you his entire life to be in the server.
And all you gave me was an 0-7 and then you keep fishing.
Holy... oh, that... that's dedication.
That's...
That's dedication right there.
She keeps fishing.
That's fucking rough, buddy.
The fishing must go on.
The fishing must... it's what he would have...
It's what he would have wanted.
True, chat.
True.
He would have wanted the same thing.
Never choose love.
Giving like wrong messages right now.
That's okay.
This is my privately owned server.
I can give whatever message I want here.
I loved him, but I love fishing more.
That's so true.
Fishing is life.
One last fish for the ride.
This is a lifestyle that we all picked and enjoy because, man, I love fishing.
You guys caught a lot of fish?
Oh, Alan.
Oh, Alan, you think I didn't see that?
Alan.
Look how much bigger I am than you, Alan.
Defend yourself right now.
Defend yourself.
Oh, oh, oh, I see.
I see.
That's right.
Get out.
Never.
Never again will you be on Doki Corp Island.
This is a private server.
This is... oh, Muds is back?
Oh, shit.
Shit.
Oh, Lamb, you're in it now, Lamb.
Muds is back.
You're in it.
You're fucking in trouble now.
He's back and he saw what you said, Muds.
He saw what you said, Lamb.
That's fucking right.
What do you have to say?
What do you have to say, Muds?
I told you, trust no... trust no... nobody.
Trust no one.
Your love was for fishing only.
You should have stayed fishing, Muds.
Romance was not the way.
Hahaha, look what you did.
I told you love wasn't the answer on Doki Corp Island.
This was... this is a fish only... I told... this is why.
This is why I made this a fishing only island.
Love only destroys you when...
When you could be using your time to fish.
When you could have been spending your time to fish.
You let love distract you.
Hahaha.
Lesson learned.
Oh my god, I'm gonna get my fish.
I'm gonna get my fish.
Okay, nice.
Oh shit, nice.
I got a bass.
Oh, and I found a lucky coin.
I told you guys.
There's a reason why...
I made sure...
There's a reason why I made sure you put your love at the table when you... before you come here.
This is what happens, guys.
It'll only destroy you for what you... for... it'll only interfere with what you truly love.
And that's fishing.
This is a fish... fish only world.
Yeah, I kicked him.
I didn't ban him.
What the fuck is wrong with you?
What is wrong with this guy?
Holy shit, his textures are going all over the place.
Oh nice, more fish.
All right, nice.
All right, that's my last fish of the day.
It was a relaxing time.
I had a great time just hanging out with... Oh, I got the ring five!
That's a good way to end it.
All right, guys.
Thank y'all for coming to Doki Corp Private Island.
I hope you guys enjoyed fishing on my private island and I hope you guys learned a...
valuable lesson.
That fishing is the only way in life.
Nothing should ever interfere with fishing.
Guys, nothing should ever interfere with fishing.
Fishing is love.
Fishing is life.
The only love you can feel is your love of fucking... is your love for fish, guys.
But like, not in the creepy way though.
Not in the like...
Not in the fucked up type of way.
Just, you know, as a hobby or everything.
Okay, guys?
All right.
I guess it's a good way to call it here.
That was fun.
I had a great time hanging out with everybody today.
It was...
It was really fun hanging out with everybody.
Just...
just relaxing and chatting and showing you guys some sneak peeks of like...
projects that are being worked on right now and like things that are being worked on.
So I'm super excited.
I'm super excited to...
and hope that things are... I can release them soon.
But yes.
Remember Thursday is when...
ticket sales come out for my first 3D concert.
And I'm super excited about that too because it's gonna be my first 3D concert.
I'm gonna be doing dance lessons and singing lessons for it.
So I can make sure to give you guys the performance you all deserve.
And it won't be... so it won't be too embarrassing for you guys to watch.
You guys won't get secondhand embarrassment.
But yeah.
I hope you guys all have a great night.
And y'all rest up.
Tomorrow is a collab with Limeo, Mint, and Snuffy.
We're gonna be playing fast food simulator.
So...
Seeing what our lives would have been if we didn't become streamers.
Hey guys!
As always, everybody stay hydrated.
Posture check.
Get up and move around to get that blood flowing.
And if you stay up for me, head to bed!
Cause you deserve it.
I'll see you guys next time everybody.
Bye guys.
Bye!